I honestly really feel like you guys are
spreading a terrible message and I'm so
sorry that you feel this way because
feminism is not a Supremacy movement
it's in a movement for equality because
women out in the world are not equal are
not equal to men how so how pick a
country in the west how so in the West
in the UK in the UK what rights do we
not have why is it that if we look at
the Oxford record of when women are
hired against men women are less likely
to be hired because they're more
expected to have babies and take
maternity leave that's not necessarily
true I mean it's like to be hired than
men let's say I'm in my early 20s and I
want to get a job they're thinking oh
she's gonna have a job and get she's
going to get maternity leave for a year
I'm going to pay her for a year but
she's not working she's less likely to
get paid than a man how can you say that
when we have quotas that are
specifically for women quotas there are
things yeah yes I am how can you how how
can you can you help me can you let me
finish it can you can you no no I'm not